Muslims are guilty of drawing the pictures
of Muhammad.
it seems they are throughout centuries we
look at the Islamic tradition and then we
get to see Muslims draw the picture of Muhammad
in the different part of the world in museums
in libraries you get to see a picture of Muhammad
you will see some of the pictures throughout
history yet today today in 21st century people
are being killed people have to hide themselves
and change their identity and people are being
fired from their job because they shown or
they drawn the picture of Muhammad
I think Muslims are just guilty let's try
to figure out what advantage first century
museums are trying to tell us regarding the
if people can draw the pictures of Muhammad
is it haram or I guess sinful to draw a cartoon
foreign
[Music]
human beings animals fish Birds is prohibited
anyone who makes images he will be punished
on the day of Resurrection [Music]
[Music] classical prohibition is mentioned
in Hadith Hadith related that the prophet
peace be upon him on the one hand said that
a funny one were to draw referring to pictures
of people then on the day of judgment God
will challenge this person to put life into
what he has drawn [Music]
what what is the ruling on this when it comes
to drawing an image of this nature the majority
position is that it is also impermissible
and this is the position of three of the four
medhips that there is never an excuse to draw
an image of a human or of an animal and this
is the default position of the hanafi school
and of the shafiri school and of the humbbelly
school so these three schools they considered
that it is impermissible for a Muslim to draw
a living being to draw anything that replicates
a living being now once school is left and
that is the Maliki School in all across the
board drawing human beings like you see a
lot of the Japanese that are doing right now
with the big eyes and stuff this is let me
say for short not good could be Haram so if
you imagine avoid drawing human beings or
living things creatures with Souls then you're
fine you're cool impermissible for a Muslim
to draw a living being to draw anything that
replicates a living being now one school is
left and that is the Maliki school and this
is now we begin our contentions and controversies
now by the way a historical note here is that
uh of course I'm not denying that uh Muslim
uh that Muslims never produced any types of
paintings or sculptures or whatnot no of course
one finds plenty of examples of this there
are manuscripts especially from the region
of Persia in the last 500 years there are
many manuscripts that you know they have been
uh Illustrated with images of angels of you
know uh uh um allegedly you know the the imams
and whatnot so they have these icons with
these are these um images there and yes you
also have you know across the Muslim World
spotted here in their uh actual uh structures
or statues carved out if you visit the Palaces
of andalus the rulers that used to live in
andalus uh the Granada Palace and whatnot
you find uh actual paintings on the walls
that they had you find uh statues of you know
horses and Eagles and and lions and whatnot
they would they would carve it out and they
had it there this was in their Royal Palace
I'm not saying it was right or wrong I'm saying
it was there [Music]
what what is the ruling on this when it comes
to drawing an image of this nature the majority
position is that it is also impermissible
and this is the position of three of the four
meth hips that there is never an excuse to
draw an image of a human or of an animal and
this is the default position of the hanafi
school and of the shafiri school and of the
humbly school so these three schools they
considered that it is impermissible for a
Muslim to draw a living being to draw anything
that replicates a living being now one school
is left and that is the Maliki School foreign
[Music]
who makes images he will be punished on the
day of Resurrection [Music]
[Music]
what what is the ruling on this when it comes
to drawing an image of this nature the majority
position is that it is also impermissible
and this is the position of three of the four
meth hips that there is never an excuse to
draw an image of a human or of an animal and
this is the default position of the hanafi
school and of the shafiri school and of the
humbbelly school so these three schools they
considered that it is impermissible for a
Muslim to draw a living being to draw anything
that replicates a living being now one school
is left and that is the Maliki School foreign
who makes images he will be punished on the
day of Resurrection this is where a lot of
yes as yesterday expressed throughout sentries
pictures of Muhammad is being drawn and shown
in U.S today in the United States today you
can go and see the picture of Muhammad in
Scotland United Kingdom you can go and see
the picture of Muhammad in London you can
go and see the picture of Muhammad as well
as in Austria in Turkey which is a museum
country in Iran you can go and see the pictures
of Muhammad since the pictures of Muhammad
can be drawn then I asked a simple question
why today people are still being killed by
the followers of Islam why people have to
hide themselves and change their identity
because they show the pictures of Muhammad
why do people need to get fired from their
job because they show the pictures of Muhammad
Muslims are guilty of drawing Muhammad by
themselves and now they want to pass that
guilt on others they want to come clean by
blaming and putting the life of others in
danger people get confused drawing human beings
animals fish Birds is prohibited anyone who
makes images he will be punished on the day
of Resurrection so we don't want to say anything
besides ignorance they're ignorant they're
ignorant . Muslims are guilty of drawing Muhammad
by themselves and now they want to pass that
guilt on others they want to come clean by
blaming and putting the life of others in
danger.
because they are ignorant.